[Music]
good evening to you thank you for
joining us at five tonight we are
celebrating las vegas history in the
making
with circa resorts grand opening i'm
brian loftis
and i'm denise valdez but before we get
to that a lot of people on unemployment
benefits could not
access their money today orco mana is
live in the newsroom with more
on what the issue was and how it was
fixed orca
well the first thing is that the nevada
department of training unemployment
and rehabilitation or dieter says the
problem was fixed at about two o'clock
this afternoon
so people should now be able to get
money from their bank of america debit
cards
bank of america is the provider for
dieter for a while today
those cards were declined when people
went to make withdrawals
in a statement dieter apologized for the
inconvenience and frustration
peter blamed the issue on a brief
systemic issue with bank of america
but did not provide more detail we just
heard back from bank of america as well
but they seem to be contradicting what
dieter is saying
they say quote the bank did not
experience any system interruption
nor was there a mass deactivation of
cards so a bit of a back and forth there
but again
we're told the issue is now resolved so
if you were declined earlier
you should be able to access the money
on the debit card now